let's talk about coming to america and
that whole thing but you know
it really is about this great love
affair you have with eddie murphy i mean
you guys are really close do i have that
relationship right
absolutely we came up at a time where we
learned this whole thing together we
went through all this together you were
a young
uh stand up in that crowd how did that
famous meeting happen
eddie would come here from new york and
i think he was in town to do the tonight
show
right uh probably around the time he was
also shooting 48 hours i think i got
that timeline right
and keenan wayans called me and said why
don't you meet us at the improv
because keenan's a new york comic and
they were friends with eddie
and he said damon my brother's coming
you haven't met damon you gotta
come meet damon and uh we all met in
front of the improv
and eddie's mother had told eddie i saw
a young man on solid gold and he did
stand up
and i think you all look like you could
be brothers i want you to
look for arsenio when you get out there
so
keenan heard that story and introduced
us
and the first thing eddie ever said to
me in in murphy fashion
he looked at me and he says [ __ ] you
don't look like me
that's the first thing you ever said to
me and then we went into improv
and uh that's so funny i have this whole
theory about
you know eddie going back and doing
stand-up comedy everybody debates it i
don't think eddie will because i think
eddie
eddie is too great his [ __ ] that he did
was so good
he doesn't want to go back and be
anything less than that we had an idea
because there's so many comics
on this i mean from tracy morgan to
michael blackson to louis anderson
uh jermaine fowler so many comics and
so i i came to eddie and i said here's a
way to get back on
we do a a tour with all these people and
you can do five minutes here you could
do two minutes
you know but that's a great way to
promote the movie i even had a title uh
coming all over america
a perfect title and he loved that and he
and and i think if there wasn't a
coronavirus pandemic
we would have got eddie on the road i
don't know what's gonna happen now
because i suggested to him
i said you know they have a drive-in
here and you can do
stand-up and people blow their horns
when it's funny and he says [ __ ] i'm
not doing stand up and no [ __ ]
driving
why don't you go to the [ __ ] driving